podemos hablar de la importancia de
dragones y estabilidad política italiana
porque el presidente solo aguanta
renault nos ha inspirado para continuar así
tanta la necesidad italiana
mercado pri después de una estrella de un estado
italia separada en este momento necesita e
la estabilidad política sigue tratando de hacer mella
mínimo euro jones sosteniendo que el
serie estrella una sumisión de judas del año
europea si tambien crimen aviones palestro
Italiano si prueba la política
necesita un gobierno es estable mario
dragones entonces representa a un hombre che
representa la institucionalidad por un lado
el tesoro encontrado garantes culo quel
Presidente del Banco Central Europeo
famoso en frase cuando las liebres mutaron
cuanto tiempo cae el banco central
dar la economía europea y decirle es el
tiempo que si eres y en un hombre
que sea capaz de crear un gobierno que vaya
fisicamente temas tiene como su unica fiesta
de oposición el partido posicionado
extrema dei reds hermanus de italia la
ubicación del movimiento 5 masacre fue y
no es una posición difícil de entender
complicado porque proporcionado básicamente ya
y la nuez italiana significa un
comisión de instagram del movimiento
brass basilio ya es de primera spa
ya el precio al cielo tambien son abetos
marcas el miércoles
polvo anna para votar sobre una moción de
llorado para gobernar un camino sucio
stop jack y precisamente como si el
carreras de valores y se mostró en la ventana
división que responde el primer ministro
ucrania para el movimiento de 5 estrellas a
liszt cracked hermanas armas país pais
que tengo entre razon y sistema x que el
coalición callejera esta es la primera
punto be amy consideración invernaderos
agresor Giuseppe Conte y Giuseppe
contar rey el frente presidente con
dry fue eliminado con una novedad
política parlamentaria de ninguna manera
y sobre la idea o sobre la manera de volver a.ser
protagonista de la escena
política italiana
en una ruptura dificil de entender
en operaciones y típicamente en política sí
personal en un movimiento el movimiento 5
estrellas jas que está en grave crisis de salsa
Ya un primero se rompía con movidas
la propia congresista mintió el rastro
en el ministro y relación hermanas lores
ex miembro derecho sobre la marcha y en
movimiento en crisis que busca y anida
Breva de fuerza A
relanzamiento y políticamente